welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the batman starring robert
pattinson directed by matt reeves
released a new trailer for international
markets with new visual clues that
challenge us once again to be one of the
world's greatest detectives but on
youtube and without any physical
exertion whatsoever i'm gonna break down
all the new evidence pointing to the
riddler's true deeper conspiracy creepy
freaking things hidden in this trailer
and some other details that you might
have missed let's get started first we
see the corpse of gotham mayor don
mitchell jr his face covered in duct
tape with no more lies written on it
making us wonder why mummify his face
like this what was done to his face that
will be revealed when this is unraveled
then the shot of the mug left by the
killer on the night of his arrest the
riddler edward nashton with a perfectly
drawn question mark in the foam and then
we hear nashton what's black
and blue
and dead all over
so some goodies there we see what looks
like nashton's dingy workshop in his
home where he likely assembled his
riddles and his death traps jigsaw style
we see his zodiac inspired signature
with a question mark surrounded by the
four cross hatches it's on a black sheet
that's hanging from the wall as if it
was a backdrop to some home videos that
he recorded of himself which we know
from other trailer footage he will
release to the media kind of the way
that real life terrorists would use
their black flag as their backdrops of
their videos but in the foreground are a
bunch of chemicals and protective gloves
on the left and then on the right some
horrifying contraption in which tubes
feed into a mask with no more lies
written on each tube i'm wondering if
this device could have been used to
force insects or rats up through those
tubes into the victim's open mouth
remember the very first teaser back in
2020 opened with the sound of someone
sucking in air as it threw a mask just
like this
[Music]
that may have actually been what was
done to mayor mitchell before his face
was taped up with these same words this
is actually almost exactly the torture
that was used in room 101 of the
ministry of love in george orwell's 1984
in which winston was rigged to a device
that forced rats to claw at his face his
greatest fear but really just seeing the
killer's home like this totally evokes
david fincher 7 a movie that we know
this batman film is going to be very
close to tonally speaking there was that
part of the movie when the detectives
arrested john doe before the film's
final act way earlier than we thought
was gonna happen and they're able to
just kind of unravel the madness of the
villain's work in his various manifestos
throughout his home then we see this
wall of photos and newspapers that
batman you seem on the left is observing
these show bruce wayne as a boy with his
parents thomas and martha wayne
attending some event with a boys choir
and directly behind young bruce is a
young edward nashton all the photos
showing that in this one moment he was
close with the wayne family and has some
history with them really all of these
photos seem to be copies or enlargements
of that one original photo at the top
there's one enlargement of thomas eyes
scratched out one enlargement of bruce
eyes scratched out then an enlargement
of edward with the question mark logo
framed around his face and across these
he wrote if only i knew then what i know
now so what was that secret well there
is a number of more recent newspaper
clippings of bruce as an adult headline
wayne spotted reclusive billionaires
seen with mystery women multiple women
nice bruce wayne had city hall for
crucial talks and then another one it's
cut off at the top but something about
the gotham orphanage renewal promise
fulfilled and then beneath that a photo
with a banner that reads wayne for mare
and it looks like thomas at a lectern
but then notice from the other photo
martha wayne is not enlarged in another
photo her eyes are not scratched out
almost like edward might have some
affection for her still and that the
price for your blind eye is a cost that
edward only applies to the father and to
the son as the guilty ones for
committing so let's put this all
together i think in this movie universe
thomas wayne was once a mayoral
candidate but there was a potential
scandal his wife martha could have had
an illegitimate son who ended up being
edward a secret lineage that edward
learned only later in life if only i
knew then what i know now making him a
secret half-brother to bruce and a
parallel orphan figure but bruce grew up
with the silver spoon in the inheritance
whereas edward was an anonymous orphan
in a crumbling foster home system we
know from other footage that nashton
writes renewal was a lie so perhaps
thomas pledge to renew gotham's
orphanage and foster kid program was
actually a false promise one never
delivered upon maybe even out of spite
from martha's bastard and this poor
nashton kid was left to suffer from
abuse that would put the wayne family at
the heart of the corruption of gotham
and leading to edward nashton targeting
all the city's leadership structure in
the present day mayor don mitchell jr
district attorney gil coulson police
commissioner pete savage all of whom
prop up and turn a blind eye to the
batman vigilante to do their dirty work
for them this would also parallel the
batman court of owl's storyline in which
talon lincoln march claims to be a
secret biological brother to bruce wayne
you know imagine watching this video and
only being able to access like half of
the easter egg videos depending on what
country you live in that's a bunch of bs
isn't it that's essentially how the
internet works and it's wrong you should
be able to access everything that
everyone else in the world can access
and that's why you need expressvpn
because there are netflix libraries in
other countries that have twice as many
oscar-winning movies as us netflix and
without expressvpn they're hiding them
just out of reach beyond that denise
guard and thanks to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video expressvpn is a
virtual private network that encrypts
your data to keep it from being stolen
or tracked and can grant you access to
blocked content open yourself up to
whole new libraries of content without
having to pay for a new streaming
service expressvpn allows you to
re-route your connection to a server in
a country of your choice making geo
restrictions a thing of the past reroute
your connection to the uk and watch rick
and morty for free or european friends
can do the reverse and enjoy all of our
us-only content expressvpn is also
helpful for preventing your online data
from being stolen or monitored without
your knowledge i like how easy
expressvpn is to use no confusion no
wasted time and the whole thing runs
fast just fire up the app and connect
with just one click it's a top-rated vpn
provider rated number one by techradar
find out how you can get three months of
expressvpn for free by visiting
expressvpn.com
new rockstars for clicking the link in
the description below but perhaps the
creepiest detail is behind adult bruce
in one of those photos in the lower
right a smile teeth visible darkened
lips this totally looks like a joker
smile this photo is actually an enlarged
and enhanced version of the photo of
bruce from the tabloid and you can see
that smile there too meaning bruce might
have been stalked by some joker figure
or maybe someone in a joker inspired
clown mask or someone holding up a photo
of this person while he was out and
about so actor barry kyogen i think the
best actor in marvel's eternals is
playing some role in this film
reportedly he's playing jim gordon's
partner stanley merkel but many believe
that that role could be a cover for
kyogen's true role the joker but rather
than a joker at the center of this
movie's plot just a relatively limited
cameo actually the hollywood reporter
reported that warner brothers tested two
different cuts of this movie one with a
certain actor one without that actor and
they decided to go forward with one of
those versions many believe that that
actor was barry kilgan playing a brief
cameo as a joker of this universe and
there are some photos you can find of
barry kilgan with a similar smile that
you can say looks a lot like that grin
behind bruce in this photo let's move
forward through the trailer among the
other shots we've seen before is this
new close-up of a photo of commissioner
savage dealing with a shady figure with
slick black hair that reminds me a lot
of heath ledger's hair in the dark
knight i'm pretty sure this is one of
the photos that are arranged in that
overhead sins of my father shot of bruce
and what i have speculated to be the
wayne family mausoleum floor with one
section devoted to savage this is likely
evidence exposing savage's corruption
maybe when he was taking bribes and why
he was targeted that would ultimately
open up things for jim gordon into the
rank of commissioner there's also a new
shot from the riddler's attack on mayor
mitchell's funeral with d.a coulson
ramming an suv into the church with a
bomb strap to his neck as people flee
bruce looks up to see someone in the
balcony the son behind this figure but
he matches the silhouette and the
overcoat of edward nashton actually this
part of the church is normally where the
church choir sings so edward is
essentially back to where he is in that
photo when he was a kid then the shot
we've seen before of bruce beating up
the guys on the train platform in the
rain i don't know if i've mentioned this
before but that scared guy on the right
is actually a cameo by jay lukergo who
plays tim drake on titans then the
international trailer ends with this
i've been trying to reach
[Laughter]
first off i love the furious strings
from composer michael jacquino and then
assuming this is the voice of edward
nashton while in police custody surprise
surprise he totally knows batman is
bruce wayne that confirms to us that all
of this is really just the riddler's
game to toy with bruce wayne and expose
the evil in the wayne family from his
point of view now paul dano's laugh in
particular scares the hell out of me
reminds me a lot of how heath ledger's
joker won a lot of us over with the
laugh alone in the 2007 teaser for the
dark knight film starting tonight people
will die
i'm a man of my word
then robertson's batman unmasks himself
in the batcave you can see the stairs of
the wayne terminus station behind him
and notice how he wrapped his hands like
a boxer before a match so that must be
how he goes into every night on patrol
he's just ready to wail on people like a
heavyweight fighter but without a
referee to hold him back i cannot wait
for this movie to come out this march so
until then to support this channel check
out some of our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching batman
[Music]
you